hey everyone i'd like to welcome
everyone to this live session on ddos
attack
also make sure to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
now let's get started let's start off
with a few interesting facts
about ddos attacks
cybercrime magazine stated that the
total number of ddos attacks globally
are anticipated to double to 14.5
million by 2022
now that's a huge number isn't it also
given the current situation with the
kovit 19 pandemic
every sector is operating virtually thus
the attacks are growing more
significantly than normal
do you know the financial brunt of ddos
attack causes
once again according to cybercrime
magazine a denial of service or a ddos
attack could cost up to
120 000 for a small company
or more than 2 million dollars for a
larger one
with financial loss even reputation gets
hampered
there are a few industries that are more
susceptible to ddos attacks and
according to the cisco reports the
online gaming
and the gambling industry are a prime
target
now let me talk about a few real-life
ddos attacks that have happened in the
past
our first example is the ddos attack
faced by dime
dine is an internet performance
management and web application security
company that was acquired by oracle
in 2016. on october 21st
2016 dine faced a serious distributor
denial of service attacks that targeted
systems
operated by dns provider dime
the dos attack lasted roughly for a day
with spikes coming and going up to 1.5
terabits per second
reports state that attack was carried
out using a weapon called the mirai
botnet
about 10 to 20 percent of all the 500
000 or so known mirai bots were involved
in addition to other devices the
findings revealed that mirai was the
primary source of malicious attack
traffic
the attack affected a large number of
users in north america and europe
several large businesses with high
traffic like amazon kora
airbnb hbo the new york times twitter
visa and cnn were affected
our next example is amazon web services
a subsidiary of amazon which works on
providing on-demand cloud computing
platforms
in the month of february 2020 amazon
stated that aws shield
observed and mitigated a 2.3 terabits
per second ddos attack
aws shield a managed edos protection
service that is responsible for
safeguarding applications running on aws
mitigated this attack
the attack was carried out using hijack
cldab web
servers and cost three days of elevated
threat for its aws shield staff
the ddos attack had a peak volume
traffic of 2.3 terabits per second which
is the largest ever recorded
detailing the attack in its q1 2020
threat report amazon said its aw shield
service mitigated the largest ddos
attack ever recorded
stopping a 2.3 terabits per second
attack in mid february this year
now that we have seen a few real-life
tdos attacks
let's move on to understanding what
exactly a ddos attack is
you might have often come across the
word denial of service attack right
so is it the same as ddos well they
differ with respect to a few parameters
a denial of service attack takes place
when a computer is used
to flood the target server or network
with traffic
by doing so its resources and bandwidth
are exhausted
the motive of the attack is to deny
normal legitimate service requests
and user access
as you can see in this image we have the
attacker's computer
sending traffic to the target server
here
now let's speak a bit about the ddos
attack
a ddos attack works closely like a
denial of service attack
the only difference is that here
multiple systems are used to launch the
attack
you can call ddos attack as a large
scale attack operation based on a denial
of service attack
ddos stands for distributed denial of
service
here several systems target a single
system with malicious traffic
when multiple systems are used the
attacker can put the system offline more
easily
ddos attack is faster than a normal
denial of service attack
and ddos attacks are difficult to trace
from this image you can see that
multiple systems are used to launch this
attack
the systems together flood the target
system with massive traffic
now that we know what a ddos attack is
let's try and understand the motive
behind these attacks
the first reason can be guessed well by
all of you and that is for ransom
just like any other cyber attack the
primary reason is monetary gain
a website owner can be asked to pay a
ransom for attackers to stop a ddos
attack
the ransom prices to stop the ddos
attacks vary from small amounts to hefty
amounts of money
in most cases the ransom is usually
charged in bitcoins
the second reason is hacktivism or
protest
hacktivism occurs with the intention of
spreading a message
the aim of this is to usually protest
against an ideology of a political
agenda
the target of many activists and ddos
attacks are government financial or
business websites
attackers launch ddos attacks to shut a
website
say for a political reason thus trying
to make a statement
a person with a financial or an
ideological motive is capable to damage
an organization by launching a ddos
attack against it
lastly these attacks can be carried out
for a specific reason
called targeted attacks for example it
can be done to damage an organization's
reputation
it is to be noted that ddos attacks can
be deployed against
big or small sites and can be driven by
either competition or pure boredom
or also for the need for challenge the
magnitude of these attacks can vary from
small
to big let's now move on and understand
a little more about the working of a
ddos attack
an attacker is required to gain control
of a network of online machines in order
to carry out a ddos attack
computers and various other iot devices
are infected with malware
and these turn into a bot also known as
a zombie
a group of such bots is called a botnet
once a botnet is created the attacker
takes over the remote control access
a ddos is usually launched through a
network of remotely controlled bots or
hacked computers
botnets can range from hundreds to
thousands of computers controlled by
hackers
it is possible that your computer could
be a part of a botnet without even you
knowing it
the next step is to target the ip
address of the victim by the botnet
once this is done each bot will bombard
the target with fake service requests
the botnets send more connection
requests than a server can handle
in some cases they send huge volumes of
data that exceed the bandwidth range of
the victim
by doing so the targeted server or
network will
overflow and thus resulting in a denial
of service to normal traffic
it is not possible to identify the bot
as it looks like a legitimate internet
device
a successful ddos attack slows a website
prevents users from accessing
it resulting in financial losses and
performance issues
so now that you know how a ddos attack
is carried out let's have a look at the
types of ddos attacks different ddos
attack vectors target the different
components of a network connection
ddos attacks can be divided into three
types
they are volume based attacks protocol
attacks
and application layer attacks let's have
a look at each one of these attacks
first up we have the volume based ddos
attack as the name suggests
this attack depends on the volume of the
inbound traffic to the target
this attack aims at overloading the
website's bandwidth or causes usage
issues
it creates a congestion by consuming all
the available bandwidth
here massive volumes of data are sent to
the victim by using a form of an
application
or request from a botnet it is very
simple the more the volume the higher
the success rate of the attack
the volume-based d-dos attacks include
udp floods
pink that is icmp floods and other
spoofed packet floods
now let's have a look at an example of
the volume based attack that is the ping
icmp flood attack the internet control
message protocol icmp which is utilized
in a pink flood attack is an internet
layer protocol
used by network devices to communicate
an icmp flood attack also known as pink
flood attack is one of the most common
denial of service attacks
here the attacker overwhelms the target
device with icmp eco requests
basically icmp eco request and eco reply
messages are used to ping a network
device to check the connection between
the sender and the receiver
an icmp request requires resources and
bandwidth to process and reply to the
requests
by flooding the target with request
packets the network is forced to respond
with an equal number of reply packets
thus making it unserviceable to normal
traffic
attackers would usually spoof in a bogus
ip address in order to mask the sending
device
the next type of ddos attack we will be
discussing about
is the protocol based attack when you
learn networking you will know that the
internet is based totally on a set of
protocols
protocol attacks cause a service
disruption by consuming
intermediate communication equipment
like firewalls
and load balancers ddos attacks based on
protocols exploit weaknesses in layer 3
and layer 4 protocol stacks
protocol based attacks exploit your
network by sending either more packets
than what your server can manage
or more bandwidth than what your network
ports can hold
this attack includes syn floods ping of
death and smurf ddos to name a few
here we will have a look at an example
of the protocol based attack that is the
syn flood attack
here the attack exploits the tcp
handshake
in a regular tcp network transaction
there is a three-way handshake
namely the syn the acknowledgement and
the sin acknowledgement
the sin is a service request the act
that is also known as the
acknowledgement
is the response from the target and the
same acknowledgement is the original
requester replying with something like a
thanks in return
whereas in the sin flood attack the syn
packets are created with
fake ip addresses by the attackers the
target as per the protocol
then sends an acknowledgement to the
dummy address
unfortunately this dummy address never
responds
this is carried out a number of times
the target waits for the final step in
the handshake and in turn it exhausts
its resources in the process
next up we have the application layer
attack the main motive of this attack is
to bring down an online service or a
website
these attacks are comparatively smaller
but silent
application layer attacks are also known
as layer 7 attacks
and it not only targets the application
but also the network and its bandwidth
application layer attacks include get
and post floods
low and slow attacks and more let's have
a look at the famous http flood attack
as an example
http flood is a type of distributed
denial of service attack in which the
attacker exploits
legitimate looking http get or post
requests
to attack a web server or an application
here large numbers of http requests
flood the server resulting in denial of
service
http has generally two types of requests
get or post a get request is used to
retrieve information
while a post request is often used when
submitting a completed web form
or when uploading a file usually http
flood attacks are harder to detect and
block
a http flood attack sends what appears
to be
legitimate http get or post requests
to attack a web server or an application
these flooding attacks
often rely on a botnet now that we had a
look at the types of ddos attacks
let's understand the measures we need to
take up in order to prevent these
attacks
the first step is to acquire more
bandwidth you must make sure that you
have
ample bandwidth to handle any spikes in
traffic caused due to malicious activity
currently with attackers being more
careful having more bandwidth
raises the bar which the attackers have
to overcome before launching a
successful ddos attack
this is a good preventive step
next make sure to develop a ddos
response plan ready
usually when a ddos attack takes place
there is very less time to plan
hence it is wise to define a plan in
advance as it will avoid
and minimize any impacts to do this job
first you would have to develop an
incident response plan
also make sure your data center is
prepared and your team knows what to do
the standard key elements include system
checklist
forming a response team which should
include the list of internal
and external contacts as well and the
last being securing your network
infrastructure
this can be done with the help of ips
that has intrusion prevention systems
which combine
firewalls vpn load balancing and other
layers of ddos defense techniques
our third point is to configure network
hardware against an attack
at times small hardware configuration
changes can help you prevent a ddos
attack
this is most often overlooked also make
sure to protect your dns servers as
attackers can bring down your website
and web servers offline by attacking
your dns servers
next point is to leverage the cloud the
conventional ddos mitigation solutions
oversize a network bandwidth and require
complex hardware
which proves to be costly and also
ineffective
whereas cloud has greater bandwidth and
resources
cloud-based apps can absorb malicious
traffic way before it reaches its
intended destination
therefore it is good to outsource ddos
prevention to cloud-based service
providers
our fifth point involves monitoring your
website traffic regularly for unusual
activities
it is a great thing if your website gets
millions of new visitors in an hour but
isn't that also suspicious
a sudden increase in traffic is an
alarming situation
hence have alerts set up in the event
you exceed a threshold specific to the
number of requests
targeting your site considering the time
and place
of the inbound traffic is also a good
step
a ddos attack usually gives a few red
flags before it happens
your team should be wise enough to spot
them beforehand
the signs of such an attack for example
will be your website being unresponsive
or responding slowly intermittent
website shutdowns or probably the user
having
problems accessing the website if these
issues are prolonged then the network is
likely experiencing a ddos and an action
should be taken immediately
the next step is to keep everything up
to date this might sound basic but it
goes a long way
all the systems should be kept up to
date to make sure that any issues or
bugs are fixed
it is always good to detect threats at
an early stage
finally you can make use of ddos
prevention tools like inferva
cloud fair f5 networks arbor ddos and
black lotus to name a few
these tools are very effective for
example cloudfire's layer 3
and 4 protection absorbs an attack
before it reaches the target server
this is not achievable by using
firewalls load balancers and routers
taking an example of arbor ddos it is to
be noted that it can deal with
large volumes of malicious traffic
without disrupting the regular traffic
this software is used to mostly protect
enterprise or web hosting services
now let's have a look at something
interesting
we will speak a bit about the digital
attack map
as you see on your screens it is a data
visualization of ddos attacks
across the world it is built through a
collaboration between
google ideas and arbor networks you can
have a look at it and explore the
various features it has
like which part of the world and when a
ddos attack is happening
you can also get all the stats related
to the attack
digital attack map lets you learn about
past trends and find reports of outages
happening on a given day
make sure to check this out with that we
have reached the end of this video on
what is a ddos attack
do you think we missed anything
important let us know in the live chat
or in the comment section below if
you're watching later
thank you for watching this video and
stay tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here